what's cracking you little gold-digging
gravity addicts about to get into this
episode Oh daddy's showing a little
upper echelon right there once you got
to take a strong hit off your own
undercarriage and fill your lungs with
some nut courage because this week we're
talking about hitchhiking finding part
of a hand in the woods we got a caller
who introduces us to the world of
legless nests
and all you've ever wanted to know about
that and could a Red Bull truck driver
be the next Vincent van Gogh we're about
to Vincent find out welcome to this past
weekend this past weekend all right
welcome to this past weekend I am Theo
von and thank you guys very very much
for joining me I know this is your time
and you are choosing to spend it here
with me on Monday June 12 and we are
here getting lively into the summertime
where the heat starts to come looking
for you and there are times in the year
when you got to go looking for the heat
you know you might fly off to the beach
or you might you might take the laundry
outside to let the you know get the
water out of it but these are times
right now when the heat comes looking
for you and I'm hot I'm hot for you
right now whoever you are I'm fired up
man I'm happy to be here with you guys
today I'm feeling fortunate to be alive
and I'm glad that we're about to share a
little bit of time together
I spent my weekend in Colusa our Friday
night I was in Colusa Colusa Casino and
that's north of Sacramento
I believe about an hour and it's good
people out there you know it's just a
lot of farm people it's rural a lot of
animals animal feces and poop and
fertilizer crops pecan groves
walnuts orchards stuff like that a lot
of fertilizer spray rigs things like
that you know a lot of people with burns
on their skin from miscellaneous
lies or errors and things like that
nature human nature happened in in
happening out there and at a good time
and I was happy to be there and just
good people man
you know lesbians regular lesbians you
know not the not the furious ones that
that hate men
just regular regular lesbians families
family values and some good diversity
out there as well a lot of Latinos
Mexicans Indian there's a strong Indian
population as well out there and
everything was going just handily I felt
like and I was happy to be there we had
a show it Colusa Casino and everybody
had had a good time I want to thank you
guys for coming out so we'll start right
there and I want to thank you for coming
out and taking a look at this bad little
mother spitter right here you know
coming out there and smelling my loud
breath that was coming off that
microphone we had a crowd of about four
or five hundred out there and it was
sheer joy I got to my accommodations out
there a man picked me up at the airport
at that Sacramento air central and I
took a ride out to the casino and this
fella talked he was chatty
you know they got chatty Cathy's out
there this was a chatty Karl this man
new words this man new words he's not a
he's not a fella you want to he's not
really a guy you if you if you got
trapped in on an island with him you'd
probably kill him early and it's it's
not even a knock against him some people
just have that infection of an chatter
ship of talkativeness where they just
want to ramble off and just show you
they know all the letters and show you
they know how to match all the letters
up and make word magic and this
gentleman was no different than that
very chatty man nice guy a murder had
actually taken place up there recently
I'm a big murder guy you know I've
always been I've always been fond of
murder and treasure you know murder and
buried treasure
y'all watch murder television I mean I
honestly I can't even sleep sometimes at
night without knowing that there is a
new murder that I don't
about that's where I'm at with it maybe
over call it an addiction a little bit
but I get keyed up you know what the
crime is in the mystery and the buried
treasure I've always thought of myself
as a treasure hunter who doesn't have
time to do his craft but maybe in the
future I get me a strong wife and I get
out there and I find uh something you
know I don't know if I find anything
that's nothing underwater I'm not doing
all that crazy [ __ ] looking out under
the water you know I'm no I'm not
extraterrestrial I'm not Aquitania s--
but I am a man who'll get out there in
the hard dirt and look for you know
Indian burial grounds or some type of
local treasure buried cache but I'm here
with you guys right now we had a good
time out in Colusa man I got settled out
there and this was interesting I
remember I walked out of the the lodging
at the casino
there's a beautiful little casino out
there and and the man who dropped me off
we've been talking about a murder that
happened up there recently a young lady
went missing they found her body and so
the second I got into the car I was
asking him about that and he knew one of
the guys who'd been accused of it so I
was a little bit roped in but I think I
asked three questions and this gentleman
had three million words so his answer to
question ratio is is off-the-charts it
was a bit much but I got settled in and
then I went out looking they had a
parade in the town in the town of Colusa
a small parade and I wanted to go see it
you know I like stuff like that
americana parades children riding sheep
or lambs sometimes they have these
events at the rodeo where they'll put a
couple of children we'll tie them onto a
sheep you know a small child or they'll
tie them onto to an athletic lamb and
let the action take place in the crowd
goes wild and you know people are
drinking their orange drinks or there's
you know sipping whiskey or secret
drinks that they're keeping in their
coats and you get to see these children
riding these lambs and it's um it's
beautiful man it's nice to see the
juxtaposition between a a a a malleable
child that can bounce around
and uh in a scared athletic sheep or
lamb it's fun to watch if you have never
gotten to see that but I walked outside
to the valet area and had four employees
working out there and I was like I want
to catch an uber in the town and the
guys like I don't know if we have any
Hoover's that come here if you want one
you have to get one from Sacramento
Sacramento is an hour away that's where
I just came in from and I'm thinking
what the [ __ ] I can't I can't get an
uber from to come get me here to take me
for miles into the town to see the
parade so then he's like we should walk
and I'm like walk dude I'm not there's
no sidewalks you know like I'll get I'll
be a freelance Trotter you know get out
there but you know it's getting around
sunset I just didn't know if it was
ideal and also what kind of advice is
this guy given this guy's the valets
telling me to walk out there you know
there's no sidewalk he's like we got a
guy that walks to work and I'm like eh
you probably had 20 guys that walked to
work but 19 of them have been hit by
cars or murdered I mean if you're
walking next to a busy highway and I'm a
murderer and I see you I mean think
about that I know a lot of you guys
listening are not murderers you know and
I know that and I'm happy I'm happy
about that and that brings me joy but
think about the fact that you're driving
and you are a murderer okay you've
murdered you know and whatever and
whatnot and you got journals about it
and [ __ ] like that you're in the game
and you see a dang hitchhiker somebody
walking by themselves I mean it's not
going to take long for whatever it is
inside of you that that finds joy and
killing others to flare up so here
you've got these valets telling me if I
want to get into town to walk it's only
four miles so that seemed a little bit
dangerous to me that didn't seem like
you know concierge type chatter you know
you think they'd have other ways and I
was like well you probably had 20 people
that walk to work but a decent amount
I've been hit by cars or probably killed
by someone so one of the other young
fellas out there pipes up because why
don't you ask somebody for
and I'm in and I know he's talking about
hitchhiking and hitchhiking I don't know
if anybody's ever hitchhiked I've done
it and I picked up a few and I'll tell
you about that shortly but this
gentleman saying hitchhike and
hitchhiking is based like you getting
into someone's car and it's kind of like
it's almost like okay who's going to
murder who that's sort of the first
moment when you get in it's like is this
two going to kill me or am I going to
flare up and kill this dude you know
hitchhike an extremely dangerous people
I think it's one of the reasons the
outlaw because people are getting killed
all the time doing it you know my
experience is with a hitchhiking or
thumbing you know are well one time I
picked up a black family a father and a
mother and a child middle of the night
they were at an abandoned vehicle took
him into town to get gasoline brought
him back they didn't say thank you
they did not say thank you I thought
that was kind of [ __ ] dude you know no
thanks I mean no thanks at all I know
I'd like to say to them right now you're
welcome brother you are welcome you
little you a couple of titty amps
because I brought y'all you know I've
got you set up and that not even say
thank you
another time I picked up a senior you
know senior citizen and I have a pension
for seniors I have a soft spot in my
heart and and in my brain I just if you
were if you could walk into my brain
you'd see a lot of seniors sitting
around and doing chess and checkers and
laughing and you know eating pudding or
eating soft snacks and sharing stories
with each other about the good days
because I have a pension for seniors you
know my father was born in 1910 so I've
always had that you know that
extracurricular love for something
minutes in its old age you know
something that's getting old and I
picked up a senior hitchhiker man and he
told me this is a story he told me this
hitchhiker he told me once he was out
there thumbing and somebody picked him
up and they start cruising and he
noticed that a policeman follows him and
then another one in the
sirens are going and then he realizes
that the guy who picked him up is in a
high-speed chase from the police and he
asks a guy he's like why'd you pick me
up and the guy tells him because he
didn't want to die alone that's what he
told them can you imagine that you just
hiked him he just trying to get
somewhere somebody picks you up because
they don't want to die alone that's how
wild it's going to get and then fast
forward I guess about 50 miles of guys
said they ended up Lodge the car was
lost in a cornfield somewhere in the
cops got him and and once he told him
what had happened ended up letting him
go but that's a wild hitchhiker story
and that man actually had a cold beer I
remember in his pocket and I thought
that that was that that was interesting
for me anyway so so yeah they wanted me
to hitchhike up there they wanted me to
multiple to walk basically at Colusa
casino I'm like you guys are more
gamblers if you guys weren't sending
them off to get murdered around here and
this is murder it's murder country up
there this is it's an environment where
you could see people go missing there's
a lot of good places to hide people but
thank you guys for joining me today man
we got we got some cool calls we had
some people called based on the
follow-up about female breadwinners we
got some amputees that called in and I'm
excited to get into that to delve into
that and learn a little bit about it
first I'm gonna tell you a little bit
more while we're on the topic of murder
I've been watching these murder shows
you know I've always been big into them
I don't know when I was a child my
mother made us watch them a lot you know
and that's what we watched who watched
America's Most Wanted as a family and
other shows like that where people were
murderers or missing and stuff and it's
a fascinating time for this kind of
stuff it's extremely popular in America
you know and when I was young accident
child they even had a criminal who was
it hiding in the woods behind our house
and I didn't know he was a criminal you
know not to sneak back there and get him
you know I'd take him um you know can
sodas and apples and an uncooked
spaghetti and packages of stuff that I
knew my mother wouldn't be upset if it
was missing and I thought he was
honestly just some lady's husband that
you know been a bad husband or hadn't
been good at husbanding and the wife had
sent him out for a while or he'd spent
time out because he wasn't doing a good
job and his husband role and because I
used to see a lot of men would go parked
behind the winn-dixie a lot of troubled
husbands and angry husbands would parked
behind the winn-dixie which is a
regional grocer and they would stay back
there and in their trucks and sleeping
their trucks and you'd see them back
there you know chew and plug - back and
smoking cigarettes and pleasuring
themselves a lot of time doing self
touch and you know playing touchy touch
and they're in the truck and the cab of
the truck and we go ride our bikes up
there and yell at them if they were
sleeping or something and fire them up
but this man was a criminal and I didn't
know there's a criminal at the time I
just thought he was Keith his name was
Keith and I called him dirty Keith in my
head but I didn't say that to him
because he was strong and I got scared
of him a lot and he would pick me up and
hold me in the air above his head you
know kind of Lion King and me and it
made me really scared but also he was
nice to me and he would chat with me and
we'd sit back there and I would just you
know bring him different delectables and
stuff like that and then police came a
couple weeks later door to door and
asking if anybody knew a criminal was
hiding and at that point I didn't want
to not know that he was a criminal I
felt a shame for not knowing out of
sight he was a you know a husband that
wasn't doing great and I told them I
told him yeah I knew it was a criminal
and I've been you know giving him canned
goods and stuff like that and stuff like
that so that was kind of a wild time for
me dealing with you know miscreants and
crime I guess another thing that
happened when I was young I found a
couple fingers in the woods a peace sign
kind of I don't know if you've ever if
you look at your hand if you give
somebody a peace sign you give them that
second and third finger in from the
thumb and I remember a buddy of mine and
I were in the woods one time looking for
cans because they had an aluminum set up
where you turned in the aluminum and
they gave you money because
these people were I don't know what they
were collected in aluminum for but
somebody said they were building a
castle or something like that and you
know a metal caste or something for the
government this is back when aliens were
big and so you you weren't surprised
that the government was out there you
know paying light money for aluminum and
metals metals different types of metals
and we found a piece on literally
somebody had gotten part of their hand
cut off the two fingers and the base of
them you know like broccoli kind of has
that base if you get a little a little
thing abraca lee it has that base before
it goes out into those the flower part
and it had that little chunk you know
the knuckles there and then it had the
two fingers and we family was in the
woods and we told a man that lived near
there that ran a little snack outlet he
ran like a snowballs and crackers or
something like that you know and a lot
of the brothers and sisters it was on
the edge of an urban neighborhood and a
lot of the brothers and sisters would
congregate over there and you know drink
lemon drinks and have snacks and we'd
get over there sometimes and and we told
him about the fingers and he called the
police and somebody came in got him put
him in a bag and took him and we never
heard anything about it again but I
remember after that in church people
would say peace be with you and I
thought that that that had something to
do with this peace sign and it always
made me nervous I'm like what does it
mean what does it mean and I had an
affinity I guess for people that were
missing fingers my father was missing a
finger when he was young
one of his siblings slammed the door on
us his I think his middle finger and and
he didn't have it when I met him when I
met him Union had that he had nine he
was running on nine and so I was
eternally looking for somebody who is
missing those two fingers missing that
peace sign you know but but I've come to
the conclusion that's why people get
killed in some of these rural areas is
because there's bad valets and there's
just ignorance I mean here were two
young fellas and I had a great time at
the casino good people but here's a
couple of valets you know in concierge
is these people supposed to be directing
me and they're telling me to walk
you know I'm entertaining people in a
couple hours they're telling me to walk
four miles basically sending me off to
my death presumably I mean because if
once you start to hitchhike man you are
destined you're destined for trouble
usually you know and so I felt like I
was destined for that but I had a great
time there a great crowd thank you for
that support thank you very much for
that support and speaking of support
actually I'll tell you this dude I when
we going to let y'all know where I'm
going to be I'm going to be in New York
City coming up on two weekends Gotham
comedy club then I'll be in Stark County
Illinois that's a fundraiser I'll be in
Nashville July 8th and 9th I need your
support there they're giving me a test
run at this theater there this at the
Zanies comedy club so come out tell your
friends if you have them in Nashville
I'd love to have your support then I'll
be in Orlando San Diego Addison near
Dallas Austin and Cleveland all in the
next four months you can find those
tickets at Theo von comm slash tour I've
got two albums on iTunes and we're
starting a patreon account this week so
that'll be later in the week I think on
the 14th we're going to go live with
some neat stuff that people are excited
about to be involved in this past
weekend a lot of neat stuff thinking
about doing this investigative murder
type of podcast as well but we'll see
we'll see about that so that's what I've
been up to man you know that's what I've
been you know it didn't get murdered out
there and I'm grateful for that and Here
I am with you today and I hope you guys
are just I hope your nuts are warm or
your you know your ovaries are freaking
fire on all cylinders and you guys are
out there making the most of the
beginning of this week there's a lot
going on summer solstice is coming you
know things are happening in the air and
you got to hold your own keep your neck
up you know I remember there was a time
I've always wanted my neck to be longer
and I've shared this with you guys but I
used to wear a neck brace at night for
about eight months trying to grow my
neck out because I saw some kids in
Africa or these women in Africa had
really long necks and they had these
stacked these kind of rings on them but
it just made my neck hurt a lot and it
made it so I couldn't hear that good for
a little while because I think it did
something bad to my
anyhow let's get into the news NBA
Finals it's happening and to me it's
boring man and to me this whole season
has been boring I've talked about a
little bit but my thought is that the
NBA and that means National Basketball
Association if their goal is to make a
money making good product then I don't
think they've succeeded if their goal is
to make a good business then yes they're
making money no doubt about it
but to me it's more like the WWE these
days you know you don't feel like it's
real there's only a couple people that
can win it and the diversity level is
one-one to me to me the diversity level
I'd love to see more diversity in the
NBA you know more white players Viet
Asian poly Grecian Mexican you know if
I'm watching the game and I see a player
that's like me I think I would feel more
connected do you feel that way what do
you think you know I'm always happy to
have my views adjusted by someone who
comes along with better ideas but you
telling me that you don't want to see
Guillermo Gomez fire off a 50-foot
three-pointer you know a beautiful
Mexican gentleman at 5:1 firing off a
50-foot three-pointer wearing Dickies
pants or overalls like he does every day
on his lunch lunch break out here in Los
Angeles come on
Mexican players love Mexican people
Mexican guys love basketball and I'd
like to see them representative NBA man
you know and I'd love to see our first
Asian coach I just want to see a little
more diversity I think I think the
game's gotten a little boring to me
politics man just got this story three
Trump students at Wall Township High
School I'm going to read this one here
in New Jersey open their yearbooks to
find that they're there Trump supporting
t-shirts had been edited out of their
photos they looked like basic posters
you would see for a campaign these that
their t-shirts nothing fancy nothing
negative and I'm not sure if the school
did this you know um
like it seems like whoever ran the
yearbook kind of did this you know it
didn't go against school policy and the
principals and the officials there said
that they're going to they're definitely
going to look into it but I'm thinking
if that were me as a child whatever your
political affiliation is it doesn't
matter but if I be upset because that's
my yearbook picture
that's the only picture you have to take
from the age 18 and under that needs to
be what you want it to be because that's
the one they're going to go back to you
go to jail boom they go back to that one
you you pass away somehow maybe if
you're hitchhiking in the town from
Colusa casino boom they go back to that
one and you you dressed special for that
you wear something you know that you
want you know that's legend [ __ ] man you
know whether you're wearing a Vanilla
Ice t-shirt or that Z cavalry Chi pants
whatever you had on I remember in my
yearbook photo I didn't want it to be
adjusted you know a lot of children back
in the day were these big jumps and
t-shirts and big Johnson was a synonym
for [ __ ] or penis or something you know
large net you know gonads and dick and
all and they had these people wear these
shirts and it was always like a man with
like a big hose and it's like big
Johnson puts out the fires you know and
it was always metaphorical these shirts
but if I don't wore my big Johnson sir
to yearbook and they to edit it out not
have been upset and it just made me
think a little bit about freedom of
speech man and it's something that I'm
noticing in America that freedom of
speech it's allowed totally but the
publication of free speech feels limited
because the publishers of a lot of media
they're not publishing people's views
that are different or that are different
than their own or that aren't in line
with layers and I don't know if I'm
right or if I'm wrong I'm happy to be
wrong but if you got some thoughts on
that hit the hotline man do you think
that freedom of speech is still where it
always has been maybe I'm crazy and it
seemed to me it's my last political
thought here but it's been
I don't even know if there's Republicans
and Democrats anymore it seems almost
more like there's mainstream media verse
like the populist party you know it
seemed to look at mainstream media
versus like farmers or vers you know
people like that
yeah mainstream media versus populist
party that's what it seems like to me
those are just some thoughts man
and that's all the news that I'm not
getting into it that much you know and
we try to say less political on this
thing that I'm not trying to turn
anybody off but I do get you know I do
worry about freedom of speech man
because you know no one should feel like
they can't speak up
nobody should that's a tough place to be
for anyone and it's hard to feel whether
you're in a classroom or a college or
you're at your place of work or anything
to feel like you can't express your
beliefs even just in curiosity because
I'm always happy to be wrong I'm happy
to be wrong I don't have to be right but
I do have to be able to ask questions
and and explain my case because
perspectives are different you know and
so people with different perspectives
are going to have different views and I
understand the man I understand how
people can have certain perspectives in
one place in certain perspectives in
another alright man let's get into some
missing limbs dude I had some great
calls this week I'm going to try I've
had it so a lot of calls about addiction
and I want to get into that I'm going to
Thursday a much how to do a follow up is
just about addiction I just want to
address some of the people that have
called with it with questions about
addiction you know that's a topic that's
near and dear to my heart
personally coming up on 11 months here
sober and feeling really grateful for
that but I was excited man I've always
been fascinated about people that are
missing limbs are they unique I call
them the unique and people's you know
the word unicorn I'd rather be a unique
corn because that's the thing about a
unicorn is that it's unique
and I love the unique man I remember
even as a child you know I went to
second grade and they had a boy in my
class that had a stutter and a stutter
is when your mouth in your brain you
know suddenly are like just remix in
words and you know dropping the beat you
know right in the middle of a sentence
and stuff like that and so your brains a
little bit wild but I remember meeting
this boy out of Sutter and I immediately
was just enamored with this fella I was
infatuated because he was different than
me you know he had this this unique
thing this unique thing that I didn't
have that I couldn't even really create
and I would try to impersonate him
constantly not out of making fun I had
no issue I had no desire to make fun of
him
I was just he was a unique corn to me he
was interesting you know and I wanted to
know a little bit more about what was
going on in his life you know and so
that's why I asked people to call in who
were missing limbs or missing appendages
because that's kind of fascinating to me
I've always had my arms and legs you
know these are my arms and I'm showing
on you on the YouTube I'm showing you
right now I got two arms and come hear
that sound that's me patting on both of
my legs but do I have I always felt like
I'll be fully armed and legged my whole
life no and that's an honest thing man
uh I've never considered myself a
candidate for full life ARMA jury and
legged jury I've always considered
myself you know somebody that could lose
something or be missing something
you know I'm absent-minded you know I I
could easily see it you know I've had
flare-ups close calls in the past they
used to cut lumber with this fella who
was mentally challenged when I was doing
farm work over there outside of Natchez
Mississippi and he lined the chainsaw up
on my leg and almost cut it off one time
he thought it was a piece of wood so
that guy was an idiot but it almost
happened to me that's what I'm saying
you know I've never felt like my arms
and legs would be with me always
and if you consider yourself a candidate
or somebody that's going to have their
arms and legs their whole life that's
kind of wild to me I think that's you
being pretty cocky don't you you know
it's pretty cocky to assume that you're
going to have your arms and legs your
entire life you're going to have them
forever just cuz you had them for a few
years so far you know it's I've been
curious as to what that universe is like
you know is it scary you know do you
feel handicapped do you do you just
adapt you know I've suffered from a
depression over the years and it's more
manageable these days but it's it's not
always perfect for sure you know and
I've let my depression get me down and
beat me down and enslave me at times
even you know enough you know I have
this it's been my almost odd at times
and I'm currently fully you know
able-bodied but I don't know if I always
will be and I wonder what it's like for
a lot of those people and we got a we
had some some people reach out through
the hotline and I want to drop that
hotline number on you really quick just
in case you don't have it that Google
Voice number and that is nine eight five
hold on guys it's coming that is nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three if you have any comments on
anything we've been discussing that are
brought up I'd love for you to hit the
hotline and share with me or any other
questions or inquiries that you have
that you want basic life suggestions on
so let's hit this call right here this
gentleman was calling in this is Patrick
let's hear from Patrick CEO what's going
on Patrick well calling in from Mobile
Alabama you wanted people to call in who
are missing an appendage Bethenny my men
I'm missing my my right leg I had cancer
twice second time they had to amputate
that a first and foremost one man we
need to do something with that haircut
okay you're grown-ass man we need to get
you a respectable haircut on what's
going on with your life but I got a dope
thing down the block ago yeah now you do
something with that [ __ ] okay man I
feel you Patrick you don't like if
you're trying to amputate my haircut huh
I feel you
I appreciate your call man I'm growing
this out maybe for the bold you know I'm
trying to represent a little bit but I
do appreciate that appreciate your call
man and I'll take that into
consideration dude let's let's let's go
onward you better you do better anyway
I don't want to hit ailment you guys
hear that part again writing down the
bluff is hook you up man you do
something with that [ __ ] man you
better you do better if you knew better
you do better that's interesting that
anyway second of all let's talk about
having life with one leg okay and I've
been missing my leg for 14 years now so
the prosthetic I got weighs 12 pounds 14
years now to put that into semblance for
some of you guys that's 14 years of the
life of a sheepish lives 15 years on
average of Fox lives 14 years what else
Bishan some Bichons can live 14 years so
just to give you guys a timeline that's
14 years all right
and he says it weighs 12 pounds up and
swinging around the frost ogre weighs 12
pounds 14 years
deaf cross dead so he's been swinging
around a prosthetic weighs 12 pounds for
14 years that should be something that's
almost some type of a record you know
it's interesting because they'll have
men in these world record contests that
are you know holding you know doing
bench pressing 225 pounds for you know
20 reps and that's a record or whatever
but they don't have a contest where and
maybe they should wear you you know for
14 years lugging 12 pounds that sounds
intense to me man if I could give you a
little medal I would let's go on word
that prosthetic also costs 80,000
dollars so every five years I have to
get a new prosthetic leg too because the
computer processor goes [ __ ] so
imagine buying a car for $80,000 deal
and then them say hey you gonna need to
buy new one in five years
damn $80,000 that's a Gucci leg bruh
attk I'm surprised you don't get jag
dude if I see carjackers next time I'll
be like guys you all should look into
some some some prosthetics you know into
synthetics we used to live actually not
far from our prosthetic dealership and
we could smell them heating them up over
there and you know these were cheap ones
I think back in the day and we'd see
them you know casing up legs and elbows
and all that [ __ ] but onward let's hear
more man this is interesting and thank
you for your call man it's really
interesting it's a some [ __ ] but uh
God sleep with a gun I think then at
that point I mean how are you going to
fall asleep then when you got 80k right
there I mean what if your wife doesn't
like you I could see her taking you Alan
just black-market in that leg especially
if after five years you got to get a new
one and then I wonder if and you can
maybe call us back Patrick and let me
know if you is there an aftermarket you
know if you if that leg runs you five
years and you're getting rid of it then
what you know do you find somebody who
don't have that much loot or doesn't
have insurance you know when you drop
that you know you drop that you know
that that appendage on Murr you hook
them up with that wheel for a discount
onwards also want to talk about the
proper staring advocacy whenever you're
a handicapped person okay or if you're a
two-legged [ __ ] like yourself so
when you have two legs you see somebody
with one leg
it's okay than you know not give a
thumbs up maybe say how you doing but
please please when you see somebody
who's handicapped don't [ __ ] break
your neck don't stop in the middle of
what you're doing and see if we're about
to fall or about the [ __ ] up yeah I
guess yelling timber is like the worst
thing you could do but that's
interesting because I feel like well
let's hear the rest of what you're
saying I'm sorry to interrupt you there
Patrick onward I'm telling you do I get
that [ __ ] all the time and they look at
us like we're [ __ ] you know like
we're not even human beings like you
know I understand if you're curious but
don't [ __ ] stare I hate when two
legged people [ __ ] stare like we're
[ __ ] idiot like I can't stand that
[ __ ] so the proper etiquette see when
you see a handicapped [ __ ] just
say hey how you doing you got questions
feel free to ask ok ok so that's good
man that's proper etiquette you see a
handicap mf'er you know and your biped
that's two legs then just give them a
nod a thumbs up is pretty cool I like to
use that sometimes or but don't don't
try to you know you don't wanna stare
too much you don't want to look too much
because they don't want to feel marvel
that you know that's interesting and
also though sometimes and this might
just be some some ego thing of mine
where I feel like I want to try and be
supportive somehow or I want to help out
but maybe that's just me feeling like
I'm just going to be boosting myself up
if I can help someone and it's not me
taken into account that this person has
been living with this injury probably
for a long time and they know exactly
how to handle themselves so that's
interesting Patrick I appreciate you
sharing that also wonder do you ever
feel Bionic maybe you can call us back
with that because I think these days
like when I was young I mean you'd see I
remember I was well I was bussing tables
out there in Tucson Arizona one time I
used to live out there in the sunshine
and not a lot of shirtsleeves out there
and a lot of people saw one eyed man do
cocaine one time out near this orange
orchard near an orchard for citrus you
know and he and this some and when I was
out there they had a man on the bus I
used to ride the bus to work and the
city bus and he had a he had a leg and
appendage and it was cheaper than what
you're riding on you know this thing was
it looked like about a $400 leg or
something probably very low-end you know
I mean like a damn it was like I used
her cell but this thing he had built an
ashtray on the side of it like one of
those old Burger King ashtrays you would
see just a little aluminum
and he are a place for it then he kind
of glued it or hooked to superglue turd
into the side of his leg and he would
cross one leg up over his regular leg
and he'd have it like at an angle and
he'd just use it as an ashtray it was
like a perfectly flat astray and I
thought that that was pretty interesting
to see people do that back then or you
know do different stunts or whatever
with it
I saw a man when I lived over in Santa
Monica he was hiding drugs in his leg
and he had a twist-off kind of metal leg
looked very World War two ish and I'd
see him begging for money and this guy
was a drug addict he was out there on
drugs and had a bunch of American and
Japanese flags and a lot of dirt all
over him and he was in a wheelchair and
he would twist his legs off and he'd
hide drugs and I mean to be out there
smoking stuff that he had hidden in his
legs and he had a very heavy leg look
very German very World War two a very
some weed sell the enemy you know
something like that
some legs were probably currently
selling to Iran or something like that
but uh anyhow this uh this this this
this information you're giving me now it
makes you wonder if people don't think
that a younger generation they see more
Bionic people you know they see more you
know these superheroes and stuff like
Iron Man and these different superheroes
that can you know that part of their
bodies are Bionic so I wonder if if
younger people might not stare because
they're intrigued almost they may see
you as a as not someone with a handicap
of someone with a a like a dope like
whatever the opposite of a handicap is
like a straight up you know like a god I
can't think of something like you just
you know extraordinary some superpower
almost but uh let's keep going unless we
look like we're barely doing some [ __ ]
then then leave us the [ __ ] alone um I'm
trying to think of well what I could
tell you about the NL missing a leg man
everything in the world changes you know
I miss being me
to get up in the morning and going
taking a piss
you know yeah yeah that's interesting
man you know it's really interesting and
I wet the bed till I was 30 and so I
didn't even a lot of time to get up and
use that gift that I had to go pee so I
guess that's just surreal that's very
lame for me to do that but I puts it in
perspective man you know when you just a
little ass thing how much more effort
you have to make now at this point
Patrick's call got cut off he called
right back
so let's tap into the second call from
him he was passed from Mobile Alabama uh
just wanna talk to you about that whole
loved one leg [ __ ] um first of all just
difference between above-knee amputation
below the knee amputation
Oh shots fired shots fired down here now
Patrick Sanders the difference between
they got beef in these leg streets you
know that they got prosciutto out in
these limb streets because there's beef
between people that have above leg and
below below leg amputations I didn't
know this
onward below the knee amputation you
know these [ __ ] act like it's -
it's the same [ __ ] it's not the same
[ __ ] you know below the knees you get to
go bike ride you can go [ __ ] rock
climbing you can ballroom dance if you
want enemy like I want to [ __ ] rock
climb I won't do that [ __ ] but you can
because when you're above the knee
you're missing two major joints or
you're missing your knee your knee joint
and you're missing your ankle so you're
all [ __ ] up in the game right now so
yeah so that's a different game so when
you see some of these people you know
who are only missing below the knee you
know you should feel differently about
them maybe than you do people that is
missing all of it you know that's really
interesting and that might have that
might adjust how I treat some people
onward so you you know you can you have
the [ __ ]
see all the people you see on the
commercials and [ __ ] when you're running
those are all below-the-knee amputation
[ __ ] they can still basically
have the same lifestyle that they'd been
home you mean because they all they miss
since their ankle joint that's it I'm
missing their [ __ ] knee so you know
they don't go through happens to have
the [ __ ] that we go through Wow
yeah I guess if you just missing that
bottom part you could throw a roller
skate on there if you couldn't even
afford you know some of these higher-end
modes of transportation like you're
running on that 80,000 dollar deal right
there let's hear some more thanks for
thanks for this info Patrica this is
exactly what I was looking for men to
just kind of get inside the mindset of
what it's like to not have them on we're
and on top of that I want to talk to you
about um remember I talked about my leg
just for walking this 80 grand okay now
let's say you want to go running those
little things those little springy
[ __ ] legs those difficult one
is a hundred and twenty thousand dollars
I'm not bullshitting you it's a hundred
and twenty thousand dollars and you can
only use that to run Wow Wow a hundred
and twenty K to run so damn like you got
to really want to run like even it like
what if you won't have a leg and you
trying to hit your family up for
Christmas you're trying to get people to
put in you're trying to literally do a
Kickstarter I mean NASA dude if you do a
Kickstarter for a leg that would trump
the game because that is so ironic and
and you're going for that you got to
really want to run because you're trying
to get people to cough up that extra 40k
I mean you probably make you prove you
want to run you can't use that for
anything else so when you talk about
people donate money they're like a lot
of it donate a hundred twenty thousand
dollars to cancer research rather than
give somebody a hundred and twenty grand
just to take and run every now and again
yes I'm saying something that when you
think about that people see that money
like oh he can he'd only just use this
to run that's it a hundred and twenty
thousand dollars that's a [ __ ]
house down here Mobile Alabama USA I'm
saying just a run you told my just to
run playoffs you suck my playoffs I feel
you dude that's right that's true you
know to be honest if that's if I'm at
the table and I got the checkbook and
I'm looking at the dude
and it's ADK to get them that regular
leg you know so we can mill around and
get to the mailbox do basic [ __ ] and
he's trying to hit me up for that extra
40k just to run and I don't even know
this dude I never seen no tape to him
you know I've never seen them on like
high school sports videos or anything
like that I got to admit it'd be hard
from the cuff up that extra 40 man Wow
so that's crazy because then it just
comes down to a financial thing and I
wonder if do you feel less like the
world doesn't care about you as much
because will does insurance help with
let's listen to some more sorry so I got
my face they're not trying to hear you
with that [ __ ] you know so it's hard
getting that money you know you know of
course [ __ ] insurance then what pay
for that [ __ ] you know III I lost my
shake if I had a chance of twice so you
know I'm 34 now so if you had cancer
burger twice before uniting 40 sit and
sure if they don't want people [ __ ] so
yes rough out here in these streets man
but you know still moving in shaking
still you know try and keep up man but
if you got any more questions or
anything like that man let me know love
before the comedy I appreciate your
shouldna respect man wow wow thank you
for the call Patrick thank you for all
that information to see that other side
of what that's like you know it
definitely makes me feel like I should
have more gratitude for what I have
going on that's for sure you know for
being biped right now are these
two-legged [ __ ] as you call us
man you know yeah that must be crazy
because you give anything to have that
extra leg at certain moments you know to
go for that jog you probably see
somebody out there with them once
running on them rolling on them 120
that's $240.00 you know and then
insurance yeah if you had cancer under
the age of 40 they're not betting that
money on you they're not going to be
like oh this dude's a prime candidate to
live long and go for a nice run the
student going to be out there
Prefontaine and you know they say no
Carl Lewis out there so they're going to
shut you down with some of that some of
those costs Wow
oh it's a lot because then you just feel
like a bill you feel like an invoice
running around at times but to me you're
not man to me do you're brave brave
[ __ ] you sound tougher than me
that's for damn sure
and I would hate to fight you because
you probably kick my ass and I'd have to
say that a duel one leg kicked my ass
man a guy with an $80,000 limb kick my
ass man but I can't say that if time
didn't get tough bro then I wouldn't
start capping on dudes that only have
just that one that got that $80,000 limb
if there's a dark market for them I
can't say I wouldn't get involved in
that man to be a hundred percent honest
with you can't say that I wouldn't but
thank you for calling about that Patrick
I really appreciate it man that's a lot
of insight and and I'm grateful you made
that call or let's jump into another
call right here and this is going back
into we we had a follow-up episode this
week about how women are the primary
breadwinners and not yet but it's
statistically that is where we are
headed and some of you guys are like
what [ __ ] you talking about well that's
fine you can feel that way that's your
reaction that's how I felt at first like
what do you mean man I'm a man we make
money you know we we're the breadwinners
you know they you know women they do
they're sada they are the the mothers
you know and those are some of our
innate jobs but I'll tell you this
statistically women are taken they're
going to be making the bread because
there are more women enrolled in
undergraduate studies right now than men
statistically college graduates make
more money than non college graduates on
average not saying for everybody your
case may be different but that means
that it is going to happen women at some
point will become the primary
breadwinners in families in America and
what does that look like for us how do
we deal with it how do we react people
like well how do you deal with it
yeah we can have a plan because we still
want to be men I still want to be a man
okay even if my wife is making more
money than me or if I have a girl I
still want to be able to be a man you
know in a society that sometimes I don't
feel like they want us to be that
anymore
so we need to figure that out and we're
figure it out together
we got a call right here that came in
let's jump on that hey boy
this is Steven I'm sorry if it gets a
little loud in here I'm dropping me feel
redbull truck and here's what I think if
this is Steven a Red Bull truck driver
thank you for calling Steven onward yeah
we're going to see women become the the
main breadwinners at least you know most
or some of them I think you might see
more men like myself get into creative
line of work you know who knows if my
fiancee was the breadwinner
I might be able to stop driving this
damn truck right here and uh you just
have that that that young Netflix money
like like my boy Bo over there and
that's it I was just thinking like man I
wish my fiancee did make more money or
the same money as me and then I could
you know maybe take a part-time job
making a little less money and be able
to you know go out there and do some
creative work well I mean this see and
this is the kind of attitude and the
kind of approach that I think is is
positive because here's the thing if we
if we battle against this and it's going
to happen
you can't fight some things you know and
this is a logical smart approach to take
and that's true maybe this is a time
where men will be able to really
flourish creatively and that's a good
thought man you know and I respect you
out there man running out there running
Red Bulls man my mother's runs delivery
she delivers our papers you know
newspapers always has my whole life and
I've helped her on a route many a times
I'm not saying papers a lot less heavy
than Red Bull but I appreciate what you
do man and I appreciate your call and I
appreciate that attitude and that'd be
awesome do maybe well maybe we will
share a stage sometime let's hear the
end of what you call Stephen so that's
it man I just think that you know if men
didn't have to work as many hours cuz I
work you know 60 70 hours a week that
I'd be able to go it and maybe draw a
picture man or
you know do a little spin up at that
polka Mike's down there and Nola you
know I'm saying but that's that man have
a great day thank you Steven thanks for
that call yeah that's a great attitude
man that's a great attitude maybe we
will maybe we'll be more time for me to
be creative well I'd love to throw in an
honestly do - damn nightgown like a male
nightgown with some room for maybe for
some snacks or a couple of cigarettes
you know and get out there and just be
natural in the living room and you know
just let the air conditioner just run up
my skirt and just hit my nuts bro
and chill out you know and draw some
pictures and do some painting maybe that
is something we have ahead of us so it's
a neat way to look at it let's take one
more call this is Sharon from Alabama
and I'm not going to get full bread into
the rest of this this um this
conversation with the female
breadwinners but if you want to leave
more more messages on the hotline about
that please do I will do a follow-up
episode about it I might delve into it
more next week in the regular episodes
the follow-up episodes usually come out
on Thursday if we have them and if I can
do it you know it's it's a lot of work
for me and I am grateful to be able to
do this but it does take a lot of time
and and also if I can keep my spirits up
it's easier for me to get out here and
do it so I hope that my spirits will be
you know up this week alright let's take
another call here this lady called I
thought this was kind of interesting I'm
a player for you really quick this is
Sharon from Alabama
haseyo this is Sharon Grammer I wanted
to talk to you I've been the primary
breadwinner in our family for almost 40
years and I would love to talk to you
about how the men in my life have been
so important in what they do and what
they bring to the table if you would let
me talk to you about that I would love
to talk to you thank you good night good
night what a sweet lady you can hear
that a little bit of southern and
Midwest hospitals I would like you to do
I'd like you to call the hotline back
that number is nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three and leave me
another voicemail
and just let me know what those men have
done in your life that has been
supportive or how it's helped you and
what it felt like to be the breadwinner
you know did you rub that in your
husband's or your family members face
how did they embrace that I think you
know we can probably learn some things
from you and I would appreciate if you
would call now the voicemail can only go
for three minutes so if you have to talk
longer than that then hang up and call
back but that's how it works and I
appreciate the calls man Patrick I
appreciate you call them talking about
the amputee man on one leg bro you out
there you riding dirty man but I respect
it
and I appreciate the people occlusive
casino I'm glad I didn't take a walk to
that pre because I might not be here
because hitchhiking dangerous and I also
thought about this man it's just a
parting thought you know a lot of
homeless out here where I live and know
if somebody's homeless out there you
know more power to you getting a home
but I don't think the homeless should be
allowed though just wander around all
day I think we should have hours where
the homeless are out and about because
what the people who are with have homes
and are doing work during the day a lot
of times traffic will get held up
because there's two homeless dudes
fighting in the street in a crosswalk or
there's a homeless guy over there above
a Highland Avenue all he does is go back
and forth across the intersections all
day that guy alone is making people's
commutes 20 minute longer and I just
think if you're not contributing to the
daily flow then let's have some hours
where you should be out and about
because if you're out and about when
people who are regular flow are out
there doing it you're not helping the
situation man you're not helping the
situation I don't have any part music to
you guys this week I got to look into
some I do have interests though if
somebody wants to help if somebody knows
how to design an app a basic app I'm
looking to hire somebody to help me do
that
I'm also looking for some intro and
outro like kind of a theme music you
know something that's kind of regular
and I'm interested in that I've had some
music submissions and maybe I'll look
back through those but those are things
that I am interested in getting some
help with and I want to thank you guys
so much
some great calls in the pen and I'm
going to get to some of those voice
messages you've left and I'm going to
make you a part of the show because I
want you to be and I'm grateful and I
appreciate it man thank you guys for
bearing with me on this episode of this
past weekend the patreon will come out
this week so that should be interesting
I think that's going to pop out on
Wednesday so hopefully that will be all
ready to rock for then on the 14th and
we can start to offer some you know
unique stuff to big fans of the show and
also create a little bit of money to
help the show go smoother get us some
better cameras you know maybe get us
into an environment where we could have
a guest in a more comfortable
environment hire a producer just little
things like that but I believe that
we're doing good stuff and I'm happy to
be able to be a conduit just to be a
part of whatever man you know and I
appreciate you guys tuning in and
listening what's going on with me for
this past weekend I'm Theo von man be
good to yourselves you probably deserve
it if you need me hit the hotline and
I'll do what I can to help out I'll try
to you know just share let's share
members keep sharing this [ __ ] dude
we're out here all right bye